[موسيقى]
انا احمد الفلوجي سوري الجنسيه من مواليد
درعا اجيت على المانيا سنه 2015 حاليا
عندي خمس فروع والمعمل الخاص بمجال العطر
بلشنا من المنزل
انا واصدقائي الاثنين
بلشنا بكميات بسيطه جدا يعني ما يقارب من
الزيوت العطريه ولتر من الكحول بلشنا
نتوسع شوي شوي الصعوبات اللي واجهتنا
بالبدايه اول شيء لنملك اللغه وما نعرف شي
بالقوانين ويعني بلشنا تقريبا من الصفر
يعني
اللي انا عم بشوفه حاليا انه هم بيعشقوا
شي اسمه اورينتالج العطور الشرقيه
العطور الثقيله يعني اللي فيها داخل فيها
الاعواد المسك العنبر هالاتجاهات
شوف اللي بيستخدم العطور الزهريه بتحسه
عاطفي اكثر
والشخص اللي بتستخدم العطور الحاده بتحسوا
انه صارم اكثر وعنده جراه الشخص لازم
يختار عطره على حسب المناسبه اللي رايح
لها مثلا انا عندي اجتماع
راح احط عطر هادئ اذا كان كمان اجتماع
مغلق يعني في مكان مغلق ما بستخدم العطور
الفواحه جدا عشان ما ازعج الاخرين احتمال
بيكون حدا عنده تحسس او شيء في بعض الدول
عم بتبيع الزيوت العطريه مباشر برول وهذا
الشيء يعني مضر صحيا لانه هاي الزيوت صنعت
لا تنخلط مع المواد الثانيه ما لا تنباع
مباشره
[موسيقى]
في عندنا نسبه كبيره من الاوروبيين عم
يشتروا من عندنا ان كان من فرنسا ولا
لوكسمبورج ولا
المان والعرب كمان ان شاء الله يعني اللي
هو الطموح انه عالميا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات